[Music]
let's go to
priyana in lexington kentucky what's up
brianna
hey how are you hey good what's up
so my question is is um i'm married
and we have two kids um we have been
having this discussion on if we should
have single friends or not
and i just wanted to ask you what your
thoughts were
tell me more
um
well
if i go way back
there's been some infidelity in the past
and i think that's kind of where it's
stemming from
infidelity on my part
so
we had split up for
a year and a half
and we just got back together
and decided to work on things we both
have kind of changed and gotten therapy
and
medication to help with our anxiety and
depression
and then an issue came up the other day
and it was um
should we even be hanging out with
single people because
you know they might
they might influence me which i don't
think they would like my single
girlfriends
could influence me to do make a bad
choice that's just where he's coming
from so yeah
so
oh this is a complex question so walk me
back to the infidelity what happened
well um
i met up with
we weren't married we were we were
really young that still doesn't you know
obviously
make my choice right really real young
16 or real young 22.
really young i was uh 19. okay all right
yeah um
my ex had reached out to me my ex from
when i was like 15 16 reached out to me
he had just gotten
back from a navy like he did four years
in the navy he reached out to me and
said he wanted to go out to eat
and i said yes and that's how that was
and
my now husband found the messages
you know went back you skipped over and
that's how that was so it started with
dinner it ended with
well
no
no but it
i wanted it to that's what the messages
were about uh okay okay and he had
enough in text so this was an emotional
affair
yeah okay yeah um
and
i guess this guy was of character and he
said no
not doing that yeah okay yeah and so
then y'all split up for a year and a
half
tell me about that yeah
um well
we
were
um we had just
we were just newly married he was you
know we were stationed on an army base
in louisiana
and he started drinking heavily
the trust issues never got solved
we just we isolated from everyone i
didn't feel like i could make friends
just a lot of toxicness and
depression and so
i left
i had mentioned to him a few times like
hey i'm not happy
you know
i shoot this is heavy um that's okay
it's all right i
i just you know the kids deserve better
i just
i just had my daughter she was three
months old our daughter she was three
months old um
and he
was not there he just wasn't there
so i just picked up the kids one day and
just left like out of the
with no questions asked because i had
felt like i told him and he wasn't
hearing me
and i'd effort offered all these other
suggestions like hey you know i'll just
move out of the house and
go get a house off of base you know so
you can still be around the kids until
you get out of the army
and he just wasn't having it so are you
are you in
are you enlisted no okay no um
and so then what brought you back
together a year and a half later
um
it's a good we went on like this
um
a little vacation together as a family
and he
had mentioned to me that you know he
just he loves me he doesn't he doesn't
he wants to be the husband and dad that
he knows he can be
and i felt the same way um okay i've
been in church for the past year and a
half and i had been talking to him about
it like when he would call and talk to
the kids and
um all right you know i felt like god
was bringing us back together
um
sometimes
i i hesitate because the
some of the faith community will will be
mean to me on the internets when i say
this but
sometimes we attribute god's calling us
into a thing
but we are not fully in
it and it can get us in a mess okay
so okay
uh god very may well be calling you into
things great but i still want you to go
in there fully ready to rock and roll
with what comes your way okay um
here's how i would answer that question
before you give me the back story
okay i've got
our
i've been married we'll celebrate 20
years here in a few weeks been married a
long time and we got friends all over
the place of all different
shapes and sizes and marital status
any kind of friend you can imagine right
i've got friends that would make bernie
sanders be like whoa let's walk this one
back to the middle some and i got
friends who would make trump be like all
right that's too far even for me so i
i've got we have friends everywhere okay
yeah um
if you were to say is it wise for
somebody who's a newlywed or
is it wise for anybody's married to go
hang out and
go do stuff and go grab drinks or
whatever with somebody who's of the
opposite gender than you and they're not
married that's not wise just not and i
know that put that has a whole bunch of
implications down the road with gender
equity all that i get all that it's not
wise it's not been wise and milo it's
just not wise right
um yeah i it doesn't even it wouldn't
even enter my mind if you went and hung
out with a bunch of
girlfriends
um who are all hanging out right and
they're not some of them aren't married
i that that isn't weird to me unless
you've got a friend who's like dude
cheat on your husband do it do it and i
don't know anybody i don't know maybe
those friends exist
none of my friends are like that
uh in fact i know friends like that
exist somewhere
your situation's a little bit different
um it sounds like you'll still have not
had
the conversation you need to have about
trust and here's what you all need the
conversation you need to have
what do you need from me
to help you
meet your needs
so that
you can help me
meet my needs
and what that means is both of you have
to sit down and say here's what i need
i need you to be home when you're here i
need to be off your phone
i need to have sex with you three times
or five times a week or one time a week
i need to go for walks with you i need
an hour of gym time i need it to be
quiet in the morning when we get up i
need it to be laughing and hugging in
the morning and wake up
what do you need
and then how can i
dedicate my life to helping you meet
those needs
and you vice versa you see how that
works okay yeah that's a totally
different approach to can i do this or
can i do that
yeah see what i'm saying i like that
yeah and
any sort of can i do this or i want to
do that but i can't do that
that's never getting to the surface of
here's what i need from you
and
man
you will see your entire relationship
roll over
when you say i need you and your home to
be fully present those needs and they do
inform behaviors and that means they
need you off your phone that means you
can't come home and drink three beers
and then expect to play with the kids
because you're not gonna be present with
them that means they should turn the tv
off and turn halo off and go outside and
kick a soccer ball with their little one
right
i need help at bedtime it's sitting down
and this could be a lot of fun for the
two of you if you have this spirit it
could be a
whining and complaining and grenade
throwing fest or it could be a blast
depending on the attitude you all both
take going into this
and so
i would recommend this you've heard me
recommend this a million times and i'll
keep doing it i think y'all should have
somebody watch your kids and y'all go
have a day retreat
and
have something cool at the end of the
day
some sort of romantic rendezvous that
y'all are both into
and start at square one and say all
right we're gonna rebuild this thing
from the floor up
what is this what do we want this thing
to look like
and what do i need and by the way needs
change a lot throughout a marriage and
so you're gonna do this again next year
you're gonna do it the year after that
and the year after that
and
man it's so great it's so great you know
what i mean
yeah it sounds
it sounds good um
it's just uh
what is it i don't know um what is it
i i struggle sometimes i think like i've
which i i get offended a lot which i'm
working on but um i feel like
in a way he's trying to control me but
he he tells me you know he probably is
controlling you he probably is yeah
because he doesn't want you to cheat on
him again
yeah he's really he's really hurt by it
yeah and most of the time we default to
our
um
our
we default to our default setting right
when something bad happens and some
people detach
some people start swinging fists some
people tighten up even tighter
right
everybody has a default setting and so
in an effort to keep you
from leaving him or cheating on him
again
he's going to suffocate you
yeah in an effort
for you to keep him happy you're going
to slowly drown yourself you see it it
doesn't just they never work that way
yeah and so let's do this let's look at
the last two three four years of your
relationship and say okay what we've
tried so far isn't working let's try
something different
let's try taking our hands off the wheel
and let's try looking at each other
because here's the thing
when you were trying to cheat on him you
didn't like yourself yeah
yeah i really didn't there's something
about you that you were trying to a
whole you were trying to like
i mean there was a thing missing that
you were trying to
wrap your heart around and
man
i want you to find that with him and
that starts with you saying here's what
i need and that starts with him saying
here's what i need and you quit being
offended if he says hey i don't like it
when you do this i love when you do this
say yes i've got new data
i'll tell you something embarrassing can
i say something embarrassing
yeah it was we've been married 16 years
i think our marriage was hanging on by a
a string of dental floss okay
and we said basically we're at this very
same like we have to just be honest and
say what it is what it is what it is
like here's what i need here and here's
what i need here and i said the words no
remember i'm a six foot two 195 pound
texas male
right
and i said the words
i have been chasing
you
i have been chasing the words i'm proud
of you from you for 25 years we dated a
long time
yeah it would really mean the world to
me if you would say the words i'm proud
i'm proud of you
and dude it was i felt like such a
weakling such a coward and such a baby
for saying that out loud
but it was the truth
and
she dropped her shoulders and said if i
had known that 25 years ago i would say
that every day
and that was something i needed that i
had it was a tool that i had kept from
her right and so now
um
now that sort of conversation happens on
the regular my house hey what do you
need what do you need for today what
does today look like for you how can i
be a part of that
i already can tell you i'm gonna need
help with bedtime on it consider bedtime
done with the kids
um i'll take care of the dogs and the
chickens whatever the thing is right
and so
it's it's sitting down saying i need
this and he may say i need total
fidelity from you
i need to be able to go off and do my
thing and not wonder for one second
is she texting some other dude
and so for you that might mean like i'm
not gonna hang out with people who
aren't married i'm gonna hang out with
couples only because that's that's that
is gonna be a gift to him and hey honey
here's what i need from you i need you
to show up at home see what i'm saying
yeah and we're going to do that sucker
together and
for 99 of the world that's entering into
territory they've never seen done that
way they've never seen relationships or
marriages work like that
and so it feels it feels like you're
giving up power it feels like you are
becoming less than
because you're taking a knee at somebody
it's in front of somebody else and
saying you could really hurt me bad but
i'm going to spend my days trying to
meet your needs
with the understanding
that you're trying to meet mine
and let's get through life together and
it sounds transactional it's not it
sounds like there's an roi here there's
not there's simply i want to love you
better so that you can love me better so
that i can love you better and then
you're talking about
roots on a tree that go to the center of
the earth
and then questions like can i hang out
with unmarried those questions just go
away they just go away they're just not
or when they do pop up you shoot you
give your husband a call like hey
so-and-so's in town would it be weird if
i and he may say yeah i don't care at
all
that makes me feel that you're like
sweet cool no problem and you're on to
the next you're on to the next
so for whatever that's worth
um that'd be my recommendation and
please go into it with a spirit of this
can be a lot of fun and go into it with
a spirit of i refuse to be offended
because my husband's gonna give me some
data on how i can love him better
and i'm going to give him some data on
how he can love me better and we're
going to make this thing special